all right looks like we're now live for
the AMA for March
2024 so good to see you here Mark uh
we've already got one question lined up
and uh it's a good one uh although I
think has has some ambiguities and big
presuppositions built into it that we'll
we'll talk about in a minute I'll just
say I just came off of a great class
session in uh my uh soic ISM and the
cardinal virtues class talking about the
virtue of wisdom and in considerable
depth from what we've got in the stoic
text so that was quite a lot of fun had
some great questions from um the
participants we got about 15 students
enrolled in that class all right so laps
nine Continuum a longtime uh attendee
and subscriber do you think philosophy
can make progress in any sense on hard
metaphysical questions if so is it
valuable so progress that's an ambiguous
term and it doesn't mean the same thing
to same people so it's one of those
questions where you know we probably
would have to say well what do we mean
by this do do we mean that like there's
something like consensus among all the
practitioners or most of the
practitioners within a field because
then you don't get much progress
not only in philosophy but in any of the
humanities or the social sciences or you
know uh in a lot of other things as well
um fields that we often take quite
seriously like law or um business or
things like that so if if that's what we
mean and we're modeling it off of
mathematics or the Natural Sciences
which themselves you know sometimes go
backwards and
forwards um no there's not going to be
any any progress but in that case why
would we care
right so we have to mean something
different by by progress in that case
like can we show that there's a
development of better argued or you know
more thought out ideas and then you know
when you look at the history of
philosophy and you don't do so by going
to philosophy textbooks or um you know
websites or stuff like that but actually
like look read through things
yeah you can see people
progressing um and we see this in all
sorts of ways I mean we know even with
what we god of the stoic texts that
there's you know progress in developing
ideas like you know what does it mean to
be in accordance with nature the ideas
get more complex now hard metaphysical
questions no consensus on that either um
there's parochial consensus so you ask
an analytic philosopher what's the hard
metaphysical question right and they may
agree with other analytic philosophers
on that but you ask a history of
philosophy person or somebody doing
something in one of the various
Continental schools and they may have
different ideas about what the hard
questions are so I don't I don't know
that that's particularly helpful either
but I think you know there is progress
but if there's progress in
philosophy um it's going to be of a
different sort than say progress in
physics you know so we would want to
figure out what do we actually mean by
progress in those
cases all right let's see what the next
question is um John how do you
understand haider's different kind of
thinking discussed in works like what is
called thinking the end of philosopy and
the task of thinking the interview Only
a God can save us I don't know because I
don't really read that stuff too much
I'm F I'm much more focused on you know
stuff like this um you know early and
middle works of of haiger so he's had
all sorts of different kinds of thinking
but I don't have much to say about that
black prairie I'm planning on jumping
into existentialism should I start with
the second sex or being and nothingness
I've already read existentialism as a
humanism I mean if you're going to jump
into existentialism I don't know why
you'd start with either of those those
are rather late works why wouldn't you
begin with earlier thinkers like um the
19th century thinkers like k guard and n
and dovi and some people consider ibson
and Tolstoy like you know the death of
even illich to be existentialist stuff
um certainly the later existentialist
thinkers are influenced by those those
early thinkers and then you know there's
all sorts of people along the way before
you get to S and
deir you know including haiger um and
yaspers and Lev shesto and great
literary works so I would I would
actually start at the beginning of you
know in the 19th century and and read
your way forward rather than just you
know picking sart and
deoir um
so let's see
um salaf
salahudin says love from Pakistan for
inspiring people like me who love
philosophy um okay that that's that's
great yeah um it must be pretty late
right now over there I imagine right uh
time zone wise so um what's maybe 11
o'clock or so um thanks for joining for
that that's kind of kind of cool so um
Boomer Anderson uh what's your approach
to kindness
so you know it's an
underrated uh virtue or aspect of virtue
that I think a lot of people tend to
leave out and kindness is quite
important for us to cultivate
interestingly you know I just mentioned
that I'm teaching a class on stoicism
and the cardinal virtues a lot of people
don't don't realize that kindness uh or
benevolence is actually one half of
Justice according to cisero who's you
know uh articulating an orthodox stoic
perspective on that and if you read
through ancient and medieval philosophy
you will find that there's lots and lots
of discussions about kindness generosity
benevolence all those sorts of things it
often gets left out by um approaches
that want to think just in terms of like
rules or rights or stuff like that but
kindness is an incredibly important part
of our our life uh JB good to see you
here says I remember m
Puchi talking about progress and
philosophy in terms of ideas that had
been discarded I found that pretty
persuasive though discarded ideas can
always be revived some some are like
discarded and rightly so and probably
never will be revived except by
crackpots um but yeah there's there's
cases where we're like well why did we
stop thinking this way when actually
this is pretty good you know um the
Revival of of stoicism m not the sort of
like you know um put up a bunch of
quotes and uh pretend like taking cold
showers makes you sto it kind of stuff
but you know actually like studying it
um that can be quite important here's
here's a book along those lines Lawrence
Becker is a new stoicism where he he
actually
says I'm going to you know uh think
about this this book um what would
actually have been the case
if stoicism never went away right let's
do a sort of hypothetical and then he
brings up some really useful ideas that
he draws on critically from from the the
stoics so yeah sometimes we we do bring
back old ideas somebody else by the way
who I think is great in talking about
coming back to this issue on progress uh
in philosophy Alistar McIntyre you know
um he thinks that it is possible to make
progress and to have decline to go
backwards in philosophy as well so all
right uh black prairie oh what works of
kard would you recommend for
beginners so I teach an existentialism
class and it's for non-philosophy Majors
it's at a uh Institute of Art and Design
here in
Milwaukee and the two pieces that I
start them with are are the crowd is
untruth and um the second part of the
two Ages which we call the present age
and I've done videos on those which you
can find they're hopefully a useful
resource for people um and then I
usually have them read parts of fear and
trembling to get you know it's a broader
more more systematic kind of work um but
we don't we don't always do all of it
but I mean those are good also the
sickness onto death if you can get
yourself past the first page where you
know the self is a relation to the
relation it gets all kind of crazy and
confusing if you can get past that um
that's that's a pretty good one for
approaching KAG guard's work as well um
I can't reach and grab kard because he's
way up on that shelf over there but you
know I wouldn't suggest like beginning
with either or because it's a big big
thick dense work you know um actually I
also really like um and I think it's
pretty
accessible the
[Music]
um uh johanes Kaka stuff
um I'm blanking on the name I want to
say philosophical investigations but
that's that's Vicken Stein but it's it's
about the range of of philosophy as
well all right Alig do you think Green
Bay will make the Super Bowl next year I
mean do I think they will no uh do I
hope they will I mean Hope Springs
Eternal especially if you grew up in the
1970s and 80s when the Packers sucked
and disappointed us uh you come out
being the kind of fan who you know
really sticks by their
team um and that's the case for both me
and my wife I mean Jordan love really
surprised people this year he's turned
out to be a great
quarterback and actually a decent person
certainly a Improvement morally and
team-wise over the previous two star
quarterbacks of Brett Favre um and uh
Aaron roders so they've got a pretty
good future ahead but so much depends on
all these other factors that are like
totally out of your control like the
other players and how well the team gels
and management and what the schedule
looks like so you know um I'm just happy
to see them doing well and um you know I
by the way the Packers are not the only
team that I I root for I also root for
the Bears except when they're playing
the Packers and the the Colts as well so
all right
um
kristus is the there a level a text of
philosophy you return to read when you
feel
down
[Music]
um no there there isn't there that's an
interesting
question um I mean I've always got so
much going on in terms of what I'm
reading for example I'm right now
rereading world is Will and
representation because I've got a client
that I'm working through the text with
um
and uh just the act of actually reading
is is good for me I'm also here's a
Plutarch because I'm teaching Plutarch
next week uh two of his texts how to
tell a flatterer from a friend and on
having many friends so I don't I don't
have like
a goto con consoling book but the act of
reading can be helpful but I I also like
reading um speculative fiction so you
know or or certain poets like RKA RKA is
a go-to for
me because he has such you know profound
ideas about uh death and those we've
loved and nature and you know stuff like
that so
um yeah I mean I might read uh so right
now I'm actually reading uh getting
ready for the worlds of speculative
fiction I'm reading the Dresden Files
the first four novels by Jim Butcher
they're really
enjoyable um and uh if I get down which
I I haven't been lately um maybe I'll
spend more time reading speculative
fiction you know so all right um Simon
Says do you think comedy is worth
studying in philosophy can you recommend
any texts on philosophy I've read
Baron's essay on humor not good oh
that's too bad I think it's good are
there any comedians you particularly
enjoy uh um as a matter of fact I will
recommend a friend and colleague of mine
from graduate school Philip Dean who is
um he teaches at University uh of
Southern University of New Hamshire and
uh he's written some articles on
philosophy of Comedy himself and humor I
mean Aristotle talks about it in the
Nick and mccan ethics also to to some
degree in other
Works um there's you know Cicero
actually says some things about jokes in
his on the oror there's like a whole
literature um spanning the centuries of
philosophers thinking about comedy and
humor there's actually something in
schopenhauer's uh part one of world is
Will and representation there's a a
chapter where he talks about that so
there's tons and tons of people out
there and you just kind of have to do
like a a search
to to find them um and they've all got
different takes on what makes things
funny none of them I would say are like
you know the definitive take on Comedy
or humor but you know there's there's
lots of stuff what is really funny
though is that some of the discussions
of Comedy humor are themselves so
serious and not not funny
so yeah all right um ruhan says I've
been wanting to get into Jean ait's book
logic and insistence I want to know if
you recommend his interpretation of
Hegel um yeah iolite is is reliable I
would say right um I have on the Shelf
back there his Genesis and structure of
hegel's phenomenology and you know when
I was in graduate school I actually
photocopied hipolit translation in two
volumes because my mentor who
specialized in uh uh French philosophy
had put all these annotations and and
I've probably got those around here
somewhere you know we used to photocopy
books way back in the day before we had
PDFs of everything and uh you know
hippolite is probably not gonna steer
you too wrong um K like with Kev who's
his contemporary you're getting kev's
Hegel right with hippolite there's a bit
more like I'm not going to intrude my
own ideas in there you know so all right
um John says any advice on a good place
to start when reading hro as a matter of
fact I I do have two things again things
when I um introduce beginners to holl so
the cartisian meditations right that's
um that's a set of lectures that he gave
to a kind a general audience and it's
giving you an idea about what he's doing
but holl also a lot of people don't know
this wrote an article on phenomenology
for the encyclopedia
britanica and you know he's telling you
what he thinks phenomenology is and and
you know where it's it's supposed to be
headed uh in that so that that's a great
place as well and when I've taught Hol
in the past which I don't do very often
um those are the texts that I've given
my my
students
um alsoo says an Ama or two ago he gave
me suggestions for exploring kamu
influences I want to say thanks for the
guidance it's been great but difficult
reading so far oh that's good yeah it's
always nice to check back in right um
tar says will we see a possible nche
session soon I don't know what you mean
by n sessions so um I do if you're
asking like am I shooting videos on N
not right now um although I I do intend
to do another um of those fake quotes
videos uh one on N because a lot of
people come up with stuff that n didn't
say and attribute it to him but I I
don't know what you mean by a n session
ask about an online class or something
because I am planning a online class in
study with Sadler
Academy down the line probably in fall
on n's birth of tragedy and genealogy of
morals his two most systematic Works um
max says don't have a question but I
wanted to thank you for the
self-directed study on K your tip of
occasionally taking a step break helps
with reading the in my uh opinion semi
Overlook second critique
um yeah yeah the second critique doesn't
actually the third critique don't get as
much love as the first critique do but K
clearly thought they were important and
I think that
they're in a lot of respects more
interesting than the first critique
myself
um and you know with K the idea of like
every once in a while stepping back and
taking a break rather than simply
plowing through it this would apply to
Hegel too and haiger and other difficult
thinkers as well
um tarx says you would love to read
Paradise Lost I've already read Paradise
Lost you know um I I've actually tutored
students on it in the
past um Shelley says I was thinking of
rereading Waiting for God godau I did a
paper on it I I found it kind of
disappointing it was one of those texts
that you know I get where it's coming
from it had been talked up so much was
being so cool and you need to read it
and I was a little disappointed when I
did read it
30 years ago as an
undergraduate
um laps 9 Continuum says I have a
girlfriend who I love unconditionally
sometimes it seems serendipitous we
found each other at all what would you
say to someone who worries they might
never find the right
person uh well I would say um you might
not ever find the right person but that
doesn't mean that you can't find a
person who doesn't suit you in many
respect
um we don't all necessarily have
soulmates I'm lucky enough to have found
mine but you know I also found people
who I wrongly thought could be that
person uh in the past um and we don't
all have to have like the best you know
romance in the world just like we you
know we don't all have to have a
career sometimes it's enough to have a
job you know so
that's probably not that consoling if
somebody really is invested in oh I've
got to find the perfect person for
myself um but you know if that's
bothering somebody maybe they want to
think about where they got the idea that
they have to find that one person from
and whether it's a good idea or not you
know um Aman says which book is best for
the basics of philosophy there is no
book that's best for the basics of
philosophy there aren't bests in general
in
philosophy and if there are bests
they're not going to be bests across the
board they're going to be best for this
kind of person or that kind of person
you know um it works that way pretty
much for all the humanities there aren't
bests like that and people who tell you
that there are are um mistaken and
probably leading you astray or they're
like you know making up lists to make
some money on
websites
um Christus I'm a medical student is
there any text you recommend on
philosophy of medicine Psychiatry
especially not an area that I specialize
in so um there's there's really no
helpful advice that I could give you
about that uh sist essayist what do you
think of Bob brandom's version of
inferentialism and his philosophy in
general it's cool that you're on a
firstname basis with good old Bob right
I'm not you know I call him Robert
myself
um but uh I don't know I'm not I haven't
read a ton of brandom stuff I've liked
the stuff that I've read but I'm not
like somebody who works on him um I
don't know his version of inferentialism
um I can't say much about his philosophy
in general other than to say that he's a
a good example of somebody who starts
out doing analytic philosophy but
because he actually cares about getting
the thinkers right and reads widely ends
up becoming more of a history of
philosophy person in the Good Sense than
just a straight out analytic philosopher
but I mean there's like hundreds and
hundreds of philosophers out there who
are big names right now and you can't
stay on top of all of these people
so all right
um let's see
here Vector says I think more effort
invest ation priority and initiative
should be enforced to find the lost
works of stoicism what's your thoughts
on this and will we ever find them in
our lifetime and who's trying I mean I
don't know what you think people would
do first of all should be enforced who
the hell is going to enforce it the
philosophy Grand Council the philosophy
police the Grand Puba of stoicism there
isn't any such thing right I
mean I don't know what what you think
people would do um and then where the
hell are you going to find these texts I
mean in the past where we found texts
are in Old libraries very often
sandwiched in between other texts you
know or you know we might luck out and
there's a cache of text that somehow you
know got preserved in dry conditions in
the Middle East and then somebody sold
them and they were found you know this
this is more like you know thinking
about the Dead Sea Scrolls or stuff like
that but you don't find that sort of
stuff very often and we've probably
found as much as we're going to um I
don't know who you think would be like
carrying out a kind of Indiana Jones
Antiquities sort of thing finding the
lost
stuff um you know maybe we'll find some
of the stuff as they're deciphering the
Scrolls at hercul and am but we don't
know I mean a lot of that looks like
it's epicurian stuff which is cool to
have our hands on but we don't know what
that person actually had in their
Library so you know prospects of it are
pretty dim um that said there's enough
stoic literature already in existence
that most people don't bother to
actually read um that you can keep
pretty busy for a while doing that again
you know I'm teaching this class that um
I'll probably offer again in the fall
after stoicon and stoic week on stoicism
and the cardinal virtues and we're like
looking at the references to virtues and
the breakdown of them in this wide range
of of texts that are available and most
of the people that are studying them are
encountering some of these for the first
time so you know all right um
let's see
[Music]
here uh Simon Says Socrates said oh was
about Socrates says the unexamined life
is not worth
living yeah I mean he said something
kind of like that um that's kind of a
paraphrase but yeah um tar says I
watched your videos on stoic philosophy
of epicus have you considered reading
about ancient Greek poetry such as Sapp
a lot of recommendations for stuff that
I would enjoy reading that I've already
read in my time I'm 53 years old started
college when I was
20 um you know I have read quite a bit
of stuff than just the things I've done
videos on um I went through a Greek
lyric poetry phase and and read a lot of
the stuff that was available and yeah
saf was good um there's all sorts of
cool things that we could do but I you
know only have so much time shy says I
would like to be stoic but I can't do it
in
practice uh well that's kind of a
strange assumption to make um and you're
probably being a little bit too
perfectionist about it when you're
making that clearly un you know
ungrounded judgment you don't have to be
all the way stoic nobody starts out
there you start incorporating some
practices and you see where they get you
you know if if it only helps you out in
one way um that's fine and you know you
could do that with studying
aristotelianism or epicureanism or
whatever you want right so all right
uh let's see Vector says how do the
stoic solidify judgments about things
good evil and indifferent as a type of
self- dialectic or logic please
elaborate on how they do this I don't
know what you mean by Logic so you know
I can't say yes or no to that because
logic means a lot of different things um
the stoics give you all sorts of advice
about how to do that you know read
senica read epicus read Marcus orelias
to a lesser extent I mean epicus breaks
things down for you and says here's the
way to look at things you know in this
situation pay attention to this those
are the ways that you actually solidify
your judgments about things good evil
and indifferent senica does even more
because we've got lots more of his
writings you know um so I don't need to
elaborate on it because I think you can
probably go into the texts and start
gleaning all sorts of great ideas about
that
um Earl says I appreciate you sharing
your interest especially music and heavy
metal what's a philosophical approach to
the its benefits to society especially
given doubts on the virtues of its
content in proximity to deviant Behavior
Beyond Rock AAR oh with heavy metal
right so um I mean you can look at
scientific studies that are out there
that show that people who are like fans
of heavy metal listening to heavy metal
actually calms them down rather than
making them aggressive there's you know
I mean how how
scientific I I'm always taking this
stuff with somewhat of a grain assault
but there's people doing research on
that um and it's not just about
catharsis it's you know something
sometimes about guiding your life and
yeah you can find plenty of heavy metal
songs that are hedonistic or you know
about occult matters but you can also
find great ideas in heavy metal songs
for example in you know Meade's peace
sells but who's buying one of my
favorite lines ever in a heavy metal
song If there's a new way I'll be the
first in line but it better work this
time right that encapsulates a whole
pragmatic attitude about change and you
know holding people accountable and
stuff like that so you know there's all
sorts of interesting directions we could
go with
that
um all right shy says def philosophers
even agree yeah of course they do I mean
otherwise you couldn't have schools of
philosophy those are people who are in
agreement with each other um if you're
asking to do all philosophers agree on
something that's a silly thing to ask
for because it's never happened and it
doesn't happen in any of the other
Humanity either you know all right um
Vector there isn't enough stoic
literature we're missing too much don't
complain about what you don't have focus
on what you do have I doubt that you've
actually read through the available
stoic literature so until you've done
that and not just once but multiple
times don't complain about what we don't
have you know
um so Jeffrey says do you work out I I
do you know I like to take walks and you
know lift weights and uh do cardio and
stuff like that um been doing a lot of
those things for for quite a long
time all right uh Tariq says I was
always wondering about how you're able
to enrich so much in your vocabulary
skills any book
recommendations no the way you build
your vocabulary is not by reading a
particular book it's by reading books by
reading authors the more that you read
and the better stuff that you're reading
the more you are building up networks of
stuff within your your mind um that help
you to develop a vocabulary I mean it it
wouldn't hurt to go and look up things
in the dictionary sometimes as well um
and by the way you know French I I had
to leg up with French because my mom and
her family are French Canadian and spoke
some French at home so I learned some
basic French but the thing that really
probably helped me the
most I got my hands on actually my mom
bought it for me on one of her trips to
Paris she got me the gigantic uh robar
the robai dictionary which is you know
French and so when I would read a French
text and I would not know a word I would
look it up in the dictionary and then I
would read the page or so about it right
and maybe I might not know all of those
words and some of them I might look up
as well and you build your vocabulary in
really great ways um that way so that
that can be helpful uh s has a good
question to to answer here would you
agree that in order to understand a
philosophical text you have to read it
only in the original language what do
you think about the translatability of
philosophy in general there isn't a
translatability of philosophy in general
and and there aren't answers to those
sort of questions there's how well can
you translate Hegel how well can you
translate uh deart how well can you
translate Aristotle and they're very
very different things there's no
philosophy in general and this purist
elitist idea that you must read it in
the original or you're not doing any
good that's silly I mean how the hell
would you know that to begin with unless
you actually have all these languages at
your disposal and you've read all these
texts in the original I mean where did
this idea come from that oh you must
read it in the original I mean there's
good translations out there and if you
know if you can read something in the
original you go back and forth from your
native language to the Greek or Latin or
whatever it's going to be I mean you
know Renee
deart um uh it's up on the high shelf
there you know the meditations was
written in Latin he didn't even
translate it into French if you're
reading the meditations in French you're
not reading the original because you
didn't read the Latin original however
the French text has things in it that
the Latin text doesn't we we want to
avoid these kind of silly
generalizations like this and you know
the idea that you Absolut in order to
understand at all a philosophical text
you have to read it in the original well
then why do we translate anything I mean
some of these things you you really
gotta think about you
know all right uh pay taxes says have
you read uh have you ever read the
philosophy of Freedom by Rudolph Steiner
no I've never read that although I've
read other schiner stuff and frankly I'm
not
impressed um I actually knew quite a few
anthroposophists I've been to the gy
onam in Dort KN in Switzerland and so
you know I I can talk pretty competently
about uh Steiner and
anthroposophy and you know it's it's a
cult you know basically when you get
down to it um a fairly benign one as far
as they go but it's you know it's some
some weird wacky
stuff um Simon says if someone is
opposed to Modern forms of therapy what
alternatives are there for them I know
Fuko criticizes aspects of modern
Psychiatry but what alternatives are
there so it's funny that you bring up
Fuko and then modern forms of therapy
and the modern forms are cognitive
behavior therapy and dialectical
behavior therapy because Fuko did not
have those in mind at all what Fuko was
thinking about was the French
establishment of his time and what would
that consist in
primarily
psychoanalysis wasn't it as it was in
Britain and the United States for a
while too the whole cognitive thing
comes much later and so you're kind of
mixing apples and oranges there and why
are you opposed to cognitive behavior
therapy I mean it's not a cure all for
everything but think about why you're
actually opposed to it and then you've
got some reasons that you might be able
to use to figure out what other
Alternatives you would go to but to
dismiss it just offand seems kind of
imprudent to me you know Vector says
what's your IQ my IQ is the kind that
says that people who are interested in
IQ are
dummies um I haven't had an IQ test
since I was a kid uh I'm not going to
give the number because uh it was you
know kind of immaterial and then people
will use it for comparison but I think
that people who think in terms of IQ
have a certain kind of stupidity that
whatever number they have I'm not going
to trust them with anything important
you know and I don't take them seriously
Mark says I've recently been reading
into the history of student protests
here in South
Africa accessibility obviously a major
concern what are your thoughts on free
education uh especially basic versus
higher oh I would I would love to see I
I think that if if we could provide free
education and you know there's there's
certainly nothing in theory preventing
that from happening then we should do
that it should become something like a a
uh human right you know uh certainly K
through 12 and and maybe even University
education in you know in in um the
develop world we certainly have the
resources that if we arrange the economy
differently we could you know we could
have like things where not everybody can
go because they're not suited for this
sort of school or something like that we
could have qualifications but we could
certainly spend some of the money that
we piss away on other stupid things on
education and make it you know very very
affordable for anybody who who desires
it you know that would be pretty
awesome um
all right uh let's see it just skipped a
little
bit uh subin do you think at the end of
our Lives we will come to terms with
everything that happened and find peace
depends on who you are and how screwed
up you are and whether you've you know
done horrible things that are going to
prevent you from doing that or whether
you've been a good
person there's no answer to that that
covers everybody
um you know I mean probably the answer
is think about what would be needed for
you to find peace at the end if that's
something that matters to you and then
start doing those things right if you
got like long-standing grudges and beefs
with people uh that you're going to hold
on to while you're dying you're probably
gonna have a crappy death you know if
you've alienated all your friends and
family um you might want to like figure
out how to rebuild those relationships
you know so that's that's a good one in
in part
right
um let's
[Music]
see ah Sunny says
um how are you finding your volunteering
and almost home cat rescue of late I was
moved by a reflective piece on medium
the Paradox of care oh good help me to
come to terms of the loss of my own yeah
so
um I I enjoy volunteering at almost home
so for those of you who don't know um a
little bit of
backstory when my wife and I got
together she had adopted she had a whole
four-legged family she had adopted two
kittens who were
about eight years old when when I met
them sassy and ensy and they were the
survivors of an apartment fire in New
York City then uh subsequently she
adopted two puppies one uh one year one
the other year there was Magnus who'd
been pretty terribly
abused and then there was amama who was
a Katrina puppy so all four of these you
know live together uh I'm I'm a animal
lover and I'm not a dog or cat person
although more of a cat person these days
I'd say and uh I became friends with all
of them some it took longer sassy and I
became friends immediately Magnus and I
pretty quickly and amama and then Teensy
took a bit more more time and Teensy
unfortunately died when she was only 12
so then it was just the three and then
we moved here to Milwaukee and then
Magnus died and then Amika died and then
it was just you know sassy and um sassy
and I became very very close she's the
animal that I Bond bonded the closest
with in all my life and we would do all
sorts of things together you may have
seen pictures of me taking her out for
walks or having me on my shoulder
and doing all sorts of things feeding
her you know she'd like to eat my food
she like to eat everybody's food
actually and so when sassy died and
we're we're coming up to about two years
of her being dead in
April um I had thought okay when she
goes I will start volunteering in some
sort of animal shelter to help out with
other cats um that way I can you know
spend time with cats and they can get
some benefit by having somebody who
likes them and is attentive and all that
but I I didn't do that right away and
then we um we are in Green Bay not for a
Packers game but weirdly enough for a
soccer game because they do this kind of
Exchange program where
um uh I don't what whatever League it
was maybe European League or Premier
League they were playing over in Green
Bay so we were up there for a weekend
um and we were downtown and we walked
past this uh cat Refuge cat shelter
and my wife Andy said hey do we want to
go in and I was like ah I don't know
this is like three months maybe after
sassy died and then we walked past it
again and Andy was like let's go in
let's go check it out so we go in we're
talking with the people and it turns out
it's a shelter for cats that have
special needs or who are terminally ill
and they they take in other cats as well
and there's a guy who you can actually
research and look up there's articles on
him he takes naps with the cats he's a
volunteer there he's a retired guy and
he introduced me to this little cat
named Agnes who had cancer she was about
maybe 11 or so and so I sat on the couch
and Agnes sat in my lap and I petted her
and she fell asleep in my lap and you
know after that I was was like yeah
maybe uh maybe this is something I want
to do and then you know we we went to um
a local Cat Cafe for my
birthday um that also works with shelter
cats and then I found out about almost
home so we went in and um back then it
was just Ernest and Maxine to FV uh
positive cats who were there in the
shelter they had others out um and
Fosters and um you know I was like ah
this is really good I I like doing this
so I started coming on weekends and then
after a while I was like I think I want
to volunteer here and so I started doing
that and I I really do enjoy it it's
it's a lot of fun to um hang out with
them um you see a lot of them come and
go I work with the ones that are kind of
shy or withdrawn or afraid and just
spend gentle time with them and um you
see them come out of their shell and
become
social and I also work with I there was
one who I I bonded with a lot Rosie she
was a naughty cat she was dominant and
so I would give her plenty of attention
um and uh she got adopted and and you
get to see all these cats get adopted
right and um that's you know kind of
kind of important you you feel sometimes
uh a little sad when they go but you
know they're going on to a good home and
you're happy that you were able to give
them love and go back to the question of
kindness kindness and
attention and you made some little
impact on their their life so I I think
that's you know for me uh quite quite
quite good um there are some volunteers
there who get kind of conflicted Ed not
because the cats are going but they
would like to do more and more and more
and there's always going to be cats and
we could say this about people in need
but you can um you know you can only do
so much and so that's that's what I do
so all right uh green is that green oino
any thoughts on reading existential
pessimism like shiron or zapa if you
want to do that go ahead if you don't
don't I mean what would my thoughts be
um is it good to read them is it bad to
read them is that what the the question
is so uh uh JB points out an important
thing in practice um when it comes down
to it very few therapists are just one
thing or
another um they will be drawing on a
bunch of
modalities um some older some newer like
internal family system narrative therapy
um yeah sain asked what do you think
about Universal basic income I think you
know if we could do that that'd be great
it's nice because it it reduces people's
anxieties about being able to stay alive
provides a basic safety net and we
certainly have enough wealth in the
economies in the developed world to be
able to do it the main things that
prevent it are um people wanting to you
know retain
uh their Privileges and wealth and rank
and stuff like that and and quite
frankly kind of sourness and resentment
on the part of other people were like I
don't want somebody else getting
something for free you know not
realizing that um lots of people get
things for free but it's done in kind of
an arbitrary halfhazard way you know
so all right
um R12 something something do you think
there's any validity and mysticism in
Revelation
what what's validity there do I think
that it's interesting to look at what
actual people who call themselves
Mystics or actual
Revelations uh from particular religious
Traditions say that's very interesting
am I going to use some sort of giant
abstract category of mysticism which
means a million different things to
other people no I don't see any use in
that so all right Elijah how many how
May Philo hegel's philosophy of
religion uh be useful for reinterpreting
the past is it off based to consider
applying it to accepting loss so two
different questions Hegel as a historian
of religions I wouldn't rely on anything
in there you know Hegel when he's doing
history is not doing any sort of real
attentive history he's trying to call
out the grand idea that's that's in that
thing and sometimes
getting things quite wrong not just with
uh religions but also with previous
philosophies too um so I wouldn't rely
on it for that that would be kind of
kind of silly um could you apply it to
accepting loss yeah why not I mean I
don't know why you would single out that
when you know there's other things about
loss or negativity or stuff in Hegel and
there's other people who more directly
talk about I'm not sure why you'd want
to go to Hegel for that but if that's
what you're reading and you want to do
something with that I guess you could
you know there's nothing necessarily
holding you back
right
um all right let's
see oh Andy is here good to see you as
well
um enjoying learning about the stoics
finding my enjoyment again quick
question what role does the concept of
living in accordance with nature play in
the practice of stoic virtues that's a
whole can of worms right um it's it's
one of those catchphrases living in
accordance with nature that um means
different things in different places to
different stoics and there's a lot of
different moving parts to it
so there's a couple things that you
could
say one is that living in accordance
with
nature very early on so by the time of
CPUs the thir scholar is um it's
distinguished as living in accordance
with the nature of the cosmos and living
in accordance with the nature of human
being which means not being an [__]
because people are [__] but being a
fully developed human being or as close
to that as we can get and that means
cultivating the virtues and eliminating
the vices so that's part of it right
there the virtues themselves in turn
help us to live in accordance with
nature in a variety of different ways so
you know for example um the stoics think
that as human beings we have a natural
social instinct which often goes wrong
so think about tribalism for example you
know um I'm going to look out for my
people screw everybody else over here
they're they're bad we're good um that
that human natural impulse to being in
groups in society can lead you to be
good to some people which is good and
then bad to other people uh who you
shouldn't be bad to and so the stoics
would come along and say well that's not
Justice here's what Justice looks like
and this is where we get like stoic
cosmopolitanism from which by the way is
going to be the theme of this year's
stoicon the big International conference
that we have every year in October which
uh my friend and colleague Harold cley
is organizing and I'm I'm
co-organizing so that's kind of a a cool
thing there um so you know these these
things kind of fit in together you can
say similar things with stoicism in
general you got a whole constellation of
ideas and they're all connected with
each other and they mean more placed in
relation to each
other all right
uh bastet why do so many people in
Academia support Frank boas the
Frankfurt School of Communism and deny
racial differences in IQ well because
they're not [__] stupid for one thing
I mean racial differences in IQ if you
actually buy into that you're an idiot
um and you probably don't want to hang
out here because
um I'll call you that you know because I
I firmly believe it and where did you
get this idea that so many people in
Academia support Frank boas or the
Frankfurt School you clearly have no
idea what Academia is like spend a
little time on an actual college campus
or university before saying stupid
things about Academia like that oh okay
so now now basad is like writing stuff
I'm just G to remove them because oh
they think Academia is Jewish okay so we
got a hardcore racist there
um well
uh
uh that doesn't have any any place here
you know uh it's ironic that we're
talking about stoic cosmopolitanism and
then we get some repugnant disgusting
racist person showing up you know I mean
one one of the things that the stoics
actually use as an example of something
that's completely
indifferent the color of a person's
skin so in ancient times you know
whether your skin was black or white or
act pink or
Olive nothing to do with anything
according to the stoics you know so yeah
all right so let's come back
[Music]
um
uh so Simon has a thing about talking to
JB about in my country for low mood
disorders you almost always receive
CBT my experience with CBT wasn't great
now I'm skeptical so here's the thing
there's two things to think about that
yeah that's the case in in a lot of
places you're probably going to get a
CBT person because that's the big thing
right now just like if you were back in
the 50s you'd get a
psychoanalyst there's good
psychoanalysts there's bad
psychoanalysts there's good CBT
practitioners there's bad ones it's
foolish to draw on one experience or two
experiences of a modality that includes
hundreds of thousands of practitioners
to decide that the modality is no good
go find yourself a better therapist who
will actually work with you and when you
go in tell them about your experience
and they might actually say oh that
person actually got CBT wrong you know
this this I think a lot of people draw
way too much uh about big movements or
approaches from looking at only one
person who practices it all right
um let's see here Terry Fox favorite
scholar of Hegel I don't have favorites
like that um I I if I want to know about
Hegel I read Hegel I don't spend a lot
of time with secondary literature I I
don't when would I have the time to
spend time on a lot of secondary
literature if it's not doing research
directly on something I'm particularly
interested in
um all right tar says where will we be
headed in our Tech industrialization of
society it seems mental and personality
disorders are doubling with advances of
Technology H we don't really know that
um there's a lot of people who like
alarmist stuff but if you read back
through history you see the the same
alarmist themes coming up every single
generation with every new thing radio
was going to destroy us for a while you
know um haiger is a great example of
that oh I don't like the mass uh thing
that's happening with radio you know and
uh how many of us actually listen to the
radio now you know oh you know the
social media is GNA rot our
brains I don't think so I
mean what's what's more likely is that
uh we have greater access to Mental
Health Resources and less stigma about
going to therapy so more people actually
go to therapy that doesn't mean that
like technology is causing it you know
you'd have to like show that there's
some sort of correlation between the two
and that's sort of stuff that sort of
social science that's tough to do you
know so all right
um let's see
here yeah we got
another uh wannabe racist here trying to
do a little code thing get rid of them
as
well um Ken oh nice to see you here says
worth reading uh Dr Donald Robertson on
the intersections between CBT and
stoicism he's got a whole book on that
as a matter of fact I think that that
might have been the first book that he
published um it's been quite a while and
he's I think he's done a second version
of it and he's he's talked quite a bit
about it we've we've also done some
video interviews together you know so um
yeah I like I like Donald he and I have
worked together on on quite a few things
and he's I mean he he he's he can
sometimes be a little bit too dismissive
of um uh non-cognitive approaches but
it's okay I just at that point we just
kind of um uh stop the conversation and
talk about other stuff uh headbutts for
fattic uh what's your opinion on Kevin
McDonald's culture of critique never
read him nor have I ever read any Edward
Dutton I don't even know who that is um
do I believe in evolution um sure I mean
depends on what you mean by Evolution
you know there's a lot of different
approaches to it out there seems pretty
straightforward that um species do
evolve we can actually observe you know
that sort of thing happening over
generations with certain organisms that
reproduce fairly quickly so I take it as
something that should be kind of
uncontroversial uh meme Master have you
read any of the newer Oxford
translations of hegel's lectures such as
the brown and Hodson translations of the
lectures of philosophy of History
haven't
um and probably won't you know I'm happy
enough with the text that I've got um
it's nice that there's always people
churning out new stuff but you know I
don't do a lot on Hegel and the
philosophy of History um and uh I mean
if somebody wants to send me a copy I'll
read it but that's that's
fine
um headbutt for fattic communism if
humans have all these years of separate
Evolution they don't um so you're you're
asking kind of a stupid question there
and uh yeah I'm gonna ban you too I
guess we I'm not sure where we got all
these uh racists popping in from but
stupid of them to come in because they
lose access to the channel forever when
they do that
uh meme Master have you read any
secondary literature on Hegel yes um I
have read some secondary literature on
Hegel we're talking about that at the
start of the thing what about hippolite
and I contrasted him to Kev so yeah um
personally I think foras into of the
scholarship is
essential um would you say this is a
fault of
yours uh I've made four Rays into the
scholarship I'm willing to bet probably
many more than you have um I did a lot
of work on Hegel in my graduate years
and back then you know spent a lot of
time doing that I've also done this
thing you might have heard of called the
half hour Hegel Series so you know uh
presumably I might have encountered a
little bit of secondary literature on
Hagel uh but you go ahead and think what
whatever you want about you know uh
about uh how important it is to make for
raay into the
scholarship um let's see
here Sabin have you played disco
alysium um I don't even know what it is
uh green bino I've been trying to find a
good intro to Virtue ethics is there one
you would recommend it's called the
nickam McAn ethics um I mean there's if
you want to actually understand virtue
ethics you read actual virtue ethic
and you participate in their you know
sort of world of thinking you don't want
to find an intro to Virtue ethics which
is probably going to be not very good
you
know
um
so let's see here
um Michael says block opposed kir
guard's view of angst and relating to
the Future How might Block's
interpretation of the future be put in
constructive dialogue I don't know I'm
not a block person so um you'd have to
ask somebody like that um Tariq can you
suggest resources and understanding
Vicken Stein's Lo uh tractatus logico
philosophicus it's very challenging to
read I mean it's really not that
challenging because the bulk of the book
is just baby logic right I mean once you
get past the very beginning part where
it's like the picture theory of language
and then you read the kind of you know
that of what you cannot speak you must
be silent and ethics and blah blah blah
is all you know mysticism it's all
basically just intralogic stuff so I'm
not sure why you're finding it difficult
to read and I'm not sure why you want to
read it because it's it's not an
important work I mean people thought it
was important 50 years ago but it's it's
not really that important to read now
you
know um
let's see Andy says sad to see you were
right about comments on YouTube um yeah
I mean I will say this it's been a while
since I've I've had a bunch of people
coming in saying stupid things um but I
block very you know very
ruthlessly so you know when people leave
stupid comments on uh videos and and and
you know uh Twitter stuff and all that I
often will uh block them as well and it
it tends to improve the
uh uh the channel in general because you
you weed out all those sort of people
and um they can go play in in their pig
pens elsewhere you know um Arty what's
your thoughts on X's reading of Hegel
not much I mean I don't pay much
attention to xek I think that he did
interesting work early on back in the
day uh um but you know he became a star
and basically he'll just like kind of
free associate stuff um I mean he's not
as bad as say Nick land in that respect
but there's not much that's being said
that I think is particularly interesting
there's lots of jargon dropping there's
not a lot of like Exposition and
argument the further you get on in GJ in
the beginning he was doing really
interesting rigorous stuff so when I
first encountered him in the
1990s you know I would actually read his
stuff but I just I don't find him that
interesting now you
know um Michael says how do you put the
reformed tradition in dialogue with
other Christian traditions in what could
the reformed tradition contribute
something worthwhile to the discussion
of Christian Redemption I don't put it
into dialogue because I I don't have any
you know I I I don't know what it would
mean for me not a reform formed person
to put somebody else's tradition into
dialogue with other Traditions that I
also probably don't belong to I think
you would want to ask a reformed person
that uh rather than than me I can tell
you that when it comes to like certain
things that I study like the
um uh Christian philosophy debates of
the 1930s and 40s there was a smaller
frankophone reform debate and there was
also a Dutch reform debate that had
almost nothing to do with the um uh
French one and
um you know the the French reformed ones
were quite interesting but they don't
get read much um Paul rur by the way was
was part of that but none of the
reformed people over here are reading
those guys if anything they're reading
you know dwey ER and and those duchies
uh who I don't really
you know pay much attention to
right
um let's
see TK what are some books you're
planning to read for this year oh I got
a whole bunch of stuff so world's of
speculative fiction we are going to be
um doing um all sorts of great things
we're doing Jim Butcher this month uh
the uh um Dresden uh uh file stuff that
turned into a TV show we got all sorts
of other cool authors lined up you know
I'm I'm probably going to read some
other speculative fiction that's outside
of that as well including going back to
the mizon books which I've really really
enjoyed I did two sessions on that um
I've always got other stuff in
philosophy that I'm rereading or reading
for the first
time so I've got lots and lots of
research to do as well um aligator have
you ever given much thought to the
philosophy of death uh topics like is
death bad for us what would immortality
be like is suicide rational enough I
mean you could look in the channel and
see that I've actually done quite a few
videos on philosophers who talk about
death and so the answer would be yes and
we we talk about it sometimes in like my
intro classes or you know things things
like like that um ethics classes it
comes up as well you know so yeah I've
I've uh given plenty of thought to it
and I've thought about it myself as
somebody who has dealt with a ton of
death both my parents are dead all my
grandparents are dead um actually my
biological parents aren't aren't both
dead that's kind of nice that I got to
know them I lost my best friend when I
was
22 uh had a number of other people
you know um so yeah I've given a lot of
thought to it in the
past all right uh Sunny says I suspect
the attention speaking trolls we've
disappointingly had to deal with maybe a
single person who's created multiple
accounts yeah let them do that then they
just keep getting multiple accounts
banned and and Rusty wrote you can set
the comments to subscribers only I know
that um but I leave I already have
things set up the way I want them you
know I don't require somebody to be part
of the channel or a subscriber to join
in on on this sort of thing it's easy
enough just to hit you know it's one
click to ban them you know forever so
all right uh
r1234 is it true that all of Western
philosophy leads back to the idealism or
materialism of Plato and Aristotle no it
is not true and here's here's a sort of
word of advice any generalization about
all of Western philosophy is probably
going to be
wrong and when
you have something like that and you're
like oh maybe there's some truth to this
you always want to read a bit more you
know if you want to know about ancient
philosophy read ancient philosophy and
then that would answer your your
question for you you notice that in
Plato you've already got like Plato's
discussing people before him right um
and so was Aristotle and there's Plato
and Aristotle aren't the only thinkers
out there shortly after them epicurus is
on the scene right doing something
different and then we get the Plato's
School takes a skeptical turn and
Skeptics are not the same thing as Plato
or Aristotle right so anytime you've got
these massive
generalizations um and somebody is
telling you them you know that person
either is ignorant or is on the make or
is doing something right that is is
trying to put forth a false and
oversimplified idea about philosophy and
you want to ask yourself why are they
doing that and why should I be paying
attention to them Simon says I often I
notice you don't often subscribe to
systematic explanations of things you're
good at avoiding generalizations have
you always been that way or did it come
with age um well I do have systematic uh
uh explanations of things it's just that
they they don't just come from one
school I'm I'm an Eclectic sort of like
Cicero who I find a kindred spirit in in
that respect as does by the way we did a
whole conversation about this masimo pig
Luchi right um does some of it come with
age yeah maybe uh because you know if
you've ever looked at my philosophical
development
videos I talk about going through phases
like a sard phase and a nche phase and a
Vicken Stein phase you know and then
you're like oh I see the whole world
through all through this person and
inevitably I've found I don't get what I
fully need from that person and that
that person often got some people wrong
or left some things out that I want to
go back to and uh and check out so um
yeah I also think that the more that you
read and study the wider you read and
study in philosophy the less
generalizations you can make about
philosophy as such you're always like
well that's cool about Aristotelian
philosophy or that's cool about decart
and the cartesians or you know things
things like that right but you you know
you kind of
specify because you you you know it's
sort of like what people talking about
cooking you know all Cuisine is based on
these three principles well no it isn't
all traditions of cuisine boil down to
either the French or the Chinese well no
that's not the case at all you know I
mean if we transpose these ideas into
other areas we can see how ridiculous
they they sound you know I only do
French cuisine you'd be like well what
about this dish that the French got from
the Italians and then put their own
twist on you know um it's it's not quite
so so simple is that all
right uh Bak do you still read lah or is
the phase really
over uh I I of course I still read Lan
you know I've actually got the acree
right here and my favorite work by him
uh the ethics of psychoanalysis you know
um but I didn't have a lonan phase I'm
not sure where you got that from um I've
you know published a few things here and
there on On LAN so you know clearly if I
did have a phase uh publishing those
things after the pH pH would be a little
bit weird wouldn't
it laps 9 continuing speaking of haiger
I've always been a little unclear about
the way heiger seems to associate
present atand entities with mathematics
would love to get your take on it um
well he doesn't associate with
mathematics as such and he doesn't
associate all present at hand things
with the mathemati or the you know um
stuff that can be Quantified
um but there and a lot of it has to do
with like the tendency in late Modern
Life to reduce things this isn't the
question concerning technology to
standing Reserve to things that we can
turn into quantities that we can you
know logistically plan and move around
and and stuff like that that's that's
basically the connection there he's not
saying that everything is you know
mathematics and some weird quasi uh
Pythagorean or weird neoplatonist way
um so all right uh JB says I've gotten a
lot of good laughs out of today don't
love the races showing up but enjoy them
getting shown up uh yeah uh now shelle
has an interesting question is the
philosophy of schopenhauer depressing to
read not at all um because first of all
you you know with any philosopher you
don't have to actually accept what
they're saying so if you're reading a
pessimistic Phil philosopher that
doesn't mean that by reading them you
have to accept everything they're saying
and then become a pessimist yourself you
know and then find the The Cure and
reading an optimist philosopher you can
read Aristotle without becoming an
Aristotelian or Renee de cart's
meditations without you know worrying
about an evil demon who's deceiving you
yourself but schopenhauer is also a
great writer I mean this is one area
where he really does stand out you know
um especially by contrast to the one
person who he's such a jerk about which
is Hegel I mean I don't like reading
schopenhauer's criticisms of Hegel
because he's basically just being a dick
you know and he had that tendency about
him as his mother points out in her
letter to him and it you know he was
particularly a jerk because Hegel got
him his job you know and he seemed to
been motivated by Envy and Malice which
his own philosophy thinks is a bad thing
right but he's certainly a great writer
um he's clear you know he's got good
style in both translation and in the
original um and you can't say that about
Hegel you know and you can't even say
that about Kant either I mean Kant has
got really interesting ideas but he's
not a joy to read whereas schopenhauer
you can really enjoy reading him I think
you know um so all right uh Luke says
how would you help someone move on from
a phase or favorite hobby horse I
wouldn't
um I don't view it as my job to help
people move on from a phase they they
need to figure out um that what they're
having a phase about however
enthusiastic they are about it isn't
going to be enough for them
and you
know I I I don't think that I need to
rush that in
people instead they have
to realize for themselves I'm not
getting what I want out of this this
person or this approach or this point of
view I mean like take say for example
being a
nian um if you do spend a lot of time
with n there there's a tendency to to um
get kind of you know jerky with other
people and oh I'm an Uber Manch or stuff
like that um but you know if you don't
like other people not liking you maybe
that'll help you shift out of that phase
right uh or if you're like a weird kind
of platin and you're like everything's
crap except for the ideal well that's
not going to last you that long I mean
you can lose yourself in contemplation
of the forms but I don't know too many
people out there do that you
know all right so
um let's see
[Music]
here laps 9 Continuum says always makes
me laugh a little When schopenhauer
Calls k a scoundrel yeah especially when
he likes K so much too uh green oino
shopau was a breakthrough for me helped
me get into that era of philosophy glad
to hear others enjoy I him yeah I mean
he's he's good there's lots of other
great people around that time uh that
are worth reading the 19th century is
full of wonderful philosophers to read
Ry what is your plan after you complete
the 30 minute Hegel videos I don't know
go back in time like what six months
when I completed the whole series I
guess I mean you do know the half hour
Hegel series ended uh quite a while ago
uh with the last video on paragraph 808
so um are you asking what I'm planning
to do with a similar sort of
approach um I'm doing anel's
prian and then Renee dart's meditations
on first philosophy I've already done
epic tetus and cidian with that same
sort of approach did that back in 2017 I
think um so you know I'm going to do
those
probably try to do some uh um
crowdfunding for for those as well and
then um I'll think about another big
book I think the next big book sort of
like the phenomenology that I'd probably
want to do would be like sarts being a
nothingness um which would be enjoyable
because sart is also a good writer which
Hegel isn't um
so
um Shelly says
what's wrong with having a phase isn't
that like a hobby something you enjoy to
do yeah I
mean it's not like a hobby because
you're saying that this is this is where
I'm gonna like rest for now um and so
you're depriving yourself of getting
into other stuff um might be worth doing
but there's nothing wrong with a phase
as such I mean there's actually some
good points about it you know if you're
obsessed with a particular philosophy
where you read all their stuff and you
think the world through it right and you
know that's that's good to do that sort
of thing but I mean do you want to
remain in a phase forever probably not
you
know
um let's see
here oh uh BC do you think there's
parallels between thei and Sublime and
Lan's idea of the
thing yeah and parallels no connections
sure I mean read Lan Lan actually talks
about the thing uh and and references
Kant um again uh one of the places to go
with that ethics of psychoanalysis right
um but we also shouldn't be like
obsessed with you know these these words
and categories o the thing o you know
that sort of sort of thing you got to be
able to explain what what the meaning
and point of it all is and this is where
a lot of people interested in
Continental philosophy I think kind of
go go
wrong uh Sabin says to people joke about
you looking like Plato due to your
physique no I and I think in part
because you know very few people
actually know much about Plato in our
culture to begin with and when they
think about him they think about him as
a philosopher and as an old guy because
of the painting and they don't think
about you know Plato means broad it was
a nickname hey big guy is basically what
what our English equivalent of it would
be um and I do sometimes get you know
hey big guy from from people uh but it's
not connected to Plato at all I suppose
I'm starting to look more like him as my
my hair goes white and my beard gets
white stuff like that right but um I
don't think there's enough cultural
awareness of PL to to make that that
work um green oino what's the difference
between analytic and cont ental
philosophy there is no Aid difference
there's a whole series of differences an
analytic philosophy hasn't remained the
same over time Continental philosophy
was never one thing it was always at
least three or four different tendencies
that blur into each other so there's no
answer to that question uh aligator does
social media challenge our relationships
to the dead such as memorialized digital
remains such as Facebook or a digital
reanimation where the deceased continue
to act with the living um I I don't see
that as challenging our relationships to
the dead I see that as affording us the
possibility of relationships at least to
our memories of the
dead right but why would it challenge
what is our relationship to the dead you
mean like they they stay dead and we
don't think about them at all you know
um and then you know you see like
somebody's Facebook page um has
memorialized them and now you're stuck
thinking about your dead uncle or
something um I don't I don't know that
that matters that much i' I've actually
been giving some thought to what's going
to happen to like my channel you know if
I should happen to die I haven't put
together like a digital will at this
point I need to get on on to that but I
also think about like what what what's
gonna happen to all these books you know
um I know some people would like them
but how do we distribute them or
anything like that right so
um let's see Luke says uh sometimes
someone close to you gets into a phase
where they spend a lot of time with a
guru when they might benefit from moving
on um yeah now a guru is a different
thing right if if somebody's like oh I
love Jordan Peterson that's not like
having a a Plato phase you know uh oh I
can't watch enough Sam Harris he's so
wonderful uh well that's not the quite
the same thing as getting into the
stoics OR n you know one is kind of up
here and Rich and has a lot of
interesting things the other is kind of
down here and is basically looking to
make money off of you and get clout and
things like that so gurus are a little
bit of a different matter with that um
Carlos says uh have you heard about the
Brazilian thinker olavo de Caro um I've
heard of him haven't read him so I I I
don't have a think about him sort of
thing because uh I don't know enough to
to actually um say oh here's yeah so
Shelly brings up a different thing with
respect to dead
people so not in social media as such
but in uh movies we have uh actors still
living on Star Wars actors who are dead
with their images being used and
interestingly when we had the actors and
and uh I think it was writer strike as
well recently one of the sticking points
was whether a person's
images could be used by the
studios to generate um CGI content of
them doing things that the actor him or
herself wasn't being paid to do and
hadn't done themselves so like using you
know what we call Deep fakes right these
These are deep fakes but in um movies or
TV
shows and the actors rightly were like
well that's that should be off limits
right because um you're essentially
ripping us off you're you're taking us
and using our our
likeness um and and I think there's
there's something worth thinking about
there I mean right now it's not very
good by the way they've done this in um
in music there was an attempt to have
like a hologram of Ronnie James Dio one
of the greatest uh singers and band
leaders in the history of heavy metal
also a brilliant guy if you've ever
watched his
interviews um they tried having a
hologram of him on stage with other um
musicians live musicians and it just did
not go well you know and do we want to
see those sorts of things
things
um Earl asks would you have thoughts on
Cornell West's writings maybe those on
pragmatism how about his broader work
politics and recent presidential
campaign I mean I think of West as
second rate and kind of a joke he was a
big deal when and especially in American
philosophy because remember I went to
Southern Illinois University Carbondale
which was one of the few places in the
United States where classical American
philosophy including pragmatism was
still very well represented in the
department and so he was a big deal in
the 1990s and I always considered his
stuff kind of weak never really took him
that seriously thought he was more about
Showmanship than other stuff and you
know him coming out to be a presidential
candidate if he wants to do that go
ahead but I don't I don't think too many
people actually do take him seriously
the people who do take him seriously are
usually kind of second rate themselves
unfortunately you
know
so
[Music]
um Simon Says is contempt in itself ever
an appropriate response to certain
people should it be used to should it
really be used to build upon the channel
Express something else I think anybody
can feel whatever the hell they want you
know
um and you know contempt means you know
looking down upon thinking less of
there's probably some people we should
think less of I think we should think
less of racists they choose to be
racists you know that's an investment on
their part they don't have to be that
way nobody's born that way so um
certainly better than taking them out
back and you know beating the crap out
of them isn't it it's pretty minor uh to
hold them up to ridicule or stuff like
that so I'm perfectly fine with that um
and you know you look at how they treat
other
people they kind of get the same thing
right uh BC do you listen any
contemporary metal
bands uh a few not not an awful
lot um I would say my favorite one
unfortunately right now seems to be
broken up and that would be Orchid the
Doom metal band uh I just love their
stuff somebody described them as they
play the songs that Black Sabbath never
got around to recording and I think
that's so accurate um there's a lot of
older metal bands that you know are
still out touring Saxon Uriah Heap and
Judas Priest are on tour together right
now which would be an amazing show to go
to but they're classic bands right
they're not newer younger bands although
some of the some of the parts are right
you look at Judas Priest you've got
um Rob hord and and Hill um both in
their 70s and then you've got uh Scott
Travis on on drums you've got Richie
Falkner and Andy sneep on guitar younger
guys in their
40s amazing shows right Saxon has
swapped out a couple parts Uriah Heap
has a couple younger guys in it but also
some older guys as well um so you know
some of these could be viewed as like
kind of uh a contemporary bands right Al
who's your favorite heavy metal
guitarist from a British
band well that's a tough one
um I
mean probably Dave Murray from Iron
Maiden although it's tough with guys
like that right you got Dave Murray and
Adrien Smith and they really you know
they fuse together I mean there's yanuk
gear is off on the side as well but
those those two guys are the the real
core of the classical
stuff um but there's so many great
guitarists out there right um it would
be easier to say who's your favorite
heavy metal basist from a British band
and that would be the same band uh Steve
Harris of Iron Maiden All right but I
also really like Jimmy Bane and he's not
he's not British he's Scot well he is
British because Scotland's part of
Britain um Jimmy Bane is I'm a real fan
of of him unfortunately he's dead um
Ian Hill I like quite a bit you know we
could talk about others as well uh
Catman do are there any interesting good
pop philosophers like xak Cornell
Chomsky other than Gregory B Sadler um I
don't know that I'm a pop philosopher
that like they are um you know there's a
lot of great people who do really good
uh accessible philosophy i' talk about
my colleague John sers you know he does
a lot of great history of philosophy
that ordinary people read he's he's he's
approachable um I mean Alistair
McIntyre's still out there in kicking
and I would trade him against all three
of those guys usj Cornell and Chomsky um
he's he's great he's also somebody who's
got great respect for the ordinary
person um but there's tons and tons of
people
doing interesting work that could be
called pop philosophy they're just not
getting the notoriety that people like
Cornell or xak or Chomsky are getting
you
know um laps n Continuum are you a fan
of Merciful Fate at all they have some
of my favorite guitar parts and Olive
metal I like them but I wouldn't say
that they're like you know in my top 10
um but you know I listen to them
sometimes um
I mean if you if you had to ask me like
who are your really
favorite
bands so I don't have a favorite if
you'd asked me when I was 16 Iron Maiden
right um if if you'd asked me when I was
26 who would it have been probably
Allison Chains or helmet you know um if
you ask me now I'll say like well you
know Iron Maiden and Judas Priest and uh
Black Sabbath and deep purple are in
there and uh uh you know Dio and all the
bands that he's been in and the
Scorpions and then you know where do we
go from there well is Raven in there
sometimes there are tank sometimes you
know uh Rat is definitely probably one
of my favorite American bands Van Halen
before van
Hagar um you know all all of these sorts
of things well what about the the thrash
guys well I liked Metallica early on but
quit listening after and justice for all
um and then you know Mega Death I still
like them never got into Slayer Anthrax
is kind of back and forth there's other
bands as well except I listen to a lot
you know and we could go on and on and
on but it's sort of like a penumbra of
different things right so all right JB
says uh if you don't like pop
philosopher which makes sense to me what
about philosophy Communicator as people
similarly situated in science tend to go
by oh that's a really intriguing idea
actually
I like that that's that's a that's a
great idea you're right people in
science are using that term we should be
using that for
philosophy that's that's a uh that's a
really interesting
idea
[Music]
um so uh we're getting a little bit over
time and I'm gonna have a event that I
got to go to so I'm going to have to
wrap it up soon so I'll take one I think
I haven't had before Isaac uh how do you
regard acinus as five ways do you think
any of them are sound I mean it depends
on what you want an argument for the
existence of God to do right um now
sound has the technical meaning and
logic of the premises are are true um so
you'd have to like you know go through
and put them into like some sort of
logical notation to say whether they're
sound or not um I I'm not a huge fan of
cosmological arguments um I I kind of
agree with Hegel that Arguments for the
existence of God are less to like
convince somebody irrevocably and you
know irresistibly with the force of
reason and they're more like expositions
of people's conceptions of what God is
you know so
um but you know when I teach them I
teach them as if they're plausible to
undergraduates and some of them seem to
to like
it um black Perry says what do you think
of black metal or what genres of metal
do you think are pretentious or
nonsensical so I'm assuming black
prairie thinks black metal is
pretentious or nonsensical um I know I'm
a big fan of Venom you know but what
Venom called black metal is very
different than what black metal turned
into and I'm just you know when it comes
to like genre metal the genres I'm more
into are predictably enough power metal
the new wave of traditional heavy metal
Doom metal and Prague metal I guess we
would say right so
um yeah I mean I I don't listen to a lot
of genre metal stuff uh and younger
people younger metal fans I think come
at metal in its history coming through
like you know all that differentiation
that happened in the 90s oh I'll say
thrash too thrash is another genre
although thrash and speed it's a little
tricky to say exactly where they begin
and end but um yeah so I think because
of when I was born and the way I grew up
I come at metal from the 70s and 80s and
then see all these different like going
off in this direction this direction and
I just didn't follow in in most of those
directions when when people were like
getting into all the different genres of
metal I was getting into alternative
music and uh grunge and stuff like that
and I was still playing you know like
when I played bass for example in
college and bands I I played a lot of
Iron Maiden and Metallica and ACDC and
Judas Priest and um Black Sabbath and
stuff like that and then I also played a
lot of Nirvana and Pearl Jam and Stone
Temple Pilots and Alice and chains and
things like that you know I wasn't like
following along these the when I played
the violent fem and I played you know
New Model Army and and things like that
so all right well I am going
to wrap up here I'll I'll take Gilbert's
thing um uh Robert Paul wolf has stated
the key to understanding cont is through
the subjective
deduction um what does he mean not a
clue because I don't watch Wolf and I
don't think there is any key to
understanding I think there's a bunch of
different Keys depending on what part of
understand we're talking about are we
talking about the theoretical you know
critique of pure reason stuff are we
talking about the moral philosophy stuff
are we talking about the critique of
judgment you know these are these are
different sides of K stuff and there's
no key to to doing all of them so all
right so I'm gonna wrap up here thanks
to everybody for joining in we do these
every month got a lot of other events
there's there's things happening every
Saturday you know we got classic metal
class which you got to sign up for the
free online class to get in on if you
want to do that we've got worlds of
speculative fiction we got uh a new uh
self-directed study video that'll be
coming out towards the end of the month
on Thomas aquinus and we're doing uh
continuing on with understanding anger
2.0 we'll be talking about Cicero so
maybe I'll see it some of these other
events otherwise I'll see you later
on